here's what would happen if a massive
solar storm hit Earth
it would start with an enormous
explosion on the sun's surface after
anywhere from 12 hours to several days a
cloud of plasma would finally reach the
Earth this space Cloud would rain down
on our magnetosphere and trigger a
geomagnetic storm here on Earth the
storm would melt our power grid
Transformers causing a global power
outage we'd lose all the information
stored on our electronics and anything
relying on the internet would shut down
too no social media to vent your
frustration in however NASA and the
space weather prediction center closely
monitor the sun's activity their
three-day forecast would give us a heads
up if our star looked suspicious
possibly giving us enough time to
disconnect Transformers and switch our
satellites into Safe Mode still you
better pack up an emergency kit with
food and money just in case because